35 days after the deadliest mass
shooting in modern American history the
country's dealing with another senseless
act of violence this time a house of
worship is a scene of the deadly
shooting in Texas history
residents of Sutherland Springs gathered
last night near the church where the
massacre took place to remember the
victims a gunman killed 26 people in the
attack during Sunday morning services
about 20 other people were injured after
a chase police found the suspect dead
with a gunshot wound inside his vehicle
CBS News has learned he is 26 year old
Devon Patrick Kelly investigators do
believe that he shot himself in the
small community of southern Springs
which is about 30 miles southeast of San
Antonio is the latest target today Jeff
boards at the First Baptist Church with
how this investigation is progressing
Jeff a lot of people still can't believe
this happened at church on Sunday
morning good morning to you Texas is
heartbroken this morning Gail you can
see behind me here this is the church
directly behind me is a Sunday school
building which is part of the church
complex and then over that you see the
steeple and then the lights from
investigators as they continue all of
their work this morning Texas governor
Greg Abbott described the massacre here
as an act of pure evil churchgoers were
gunned down shortly after they settled
in for the start of Sunday morning
services investigators do not know at
this point if the suspect is any
connection to terrorism but yesterday he
came to this house of worship dressed in
all black apparently prepared to inflict
all this damage the English in a small
town after police say Devon Patrick
Kelly opened fire and killed over two
dozen worshippers at the First Baptist
Church I saw the guy and to know that
that's what she was doing it just
you your mind I want to process it
investigators say the suspect was first
spotted at a Valero gas station across
the street around 11:20 a.m. Sunday that
suspect crossed the street to the church
Exodus vehicle and began firing at the
church the suspect then moved to the
right side of the church and continued
to fire trust an all-black tactical gear
and a ballistic vest Kelly went inside
and kept firing his ar-15 type rifle
soon after he returned outside where a
neighbor engaged him in a gun battle I
just pulled up to an intersection and
saw a gunfire Jonny Lang and orphaned
that neighbor chased after the gunman as
he fled the scene the gentleman and the
right with the rifle came to my truck as
the shooter took off and he briefly he
briefed me quickly on what it just
happened and said that we had to get him
and we just take pursuit and we like I
said we hit about 95 I was trying to
catch this guy until he eventually lost
control on his own and went off in the
ditch
he just hurts so many people and he just
affected so many people's lives why
wouldn't you want to take him down when
police arrived a few minutes later they
found the suspect dead in the driver's
seat CBS News has learned Kelly served
at Holloman Air Force Base in New Mexico
from 2010 to 2014 he was court-martialed
in 2012 on charges he assaulted his
spouse and child
Kelly was sentenced to 12 months
confinement and received a bad conduct
discharge